a group of well-armed mobile task force
members entered the containment chamber
armed to the teeth some face the ground
droplets of sweat dripping onto their
visors some wore dr dan's infamous
scramble goggles and one particularly
brave member of personnel wielded only a
bag the room they were currently
standing in was perhaps the most
dangerous place in the world why because
it contained two terrifying titans of
the anomalous world
scp-682 the infinitely hateful hard to
destroy reptile and
scp-096 the shy guy the ultimate
mindless killing machine and if the very
idea of having them in the same place
doesn't feel risky enough the deadly duo
had just spent 27 hours in one of the
most brutal brawls imaginable and
incidentally fights like this are
exactly why we're here today we cover a
lot of scps on this channel and we've
seen the way some of the most dangerous
anomalies out there can tear their way
through civilians and train foundation
mtf operatives with ease but how do they
fare against monsters maniacs and
reality benders their own size with the
help of the scp-explained audience we're
going to explore theoretical fights
between some of the anomalous world's
biggest badasses and who better to get
this show on the road than two of the
most iconic and deadly monsters that
haunt the halls of a foundation
containment site near you the hard to
destroy reptile and the shy guy are
household names for anyone familiar with
the scp foundation and before we get
into the gruesome results of their first
fight and your theories about how a
potential rematch might play out let's
get to know the combat progress of this
pair of nasty customers what kind of
damage are they capable of taking and
inflicting spoiler alert it's a hell of
a lot in this corner we have scp-682
a monster whose ability to survive
seemingly anything is only equal by its
terrible attitude towards pretty much
everyone and everything around it though
to be fair you'd probably be a little
grumpy too if the scp foundation was
constantly trying to murder you in
different ways rather than just keeping
you contained 682's basic offensive
power set involves impressive strength
speed intelligence and the aid of its
deadly fangs claws and tail however 682
is considerably stronger after it's just
survived and regenerated from a
termination attempt that's because the
true combat asset of 682 is and always
has been its adaptability specifically
if some kind of attack brings 682 into a
state of near death but doesn't finish
the job 682 will generally either
develop a perfect defense or
counter-offensive for that attack or
somehow add a version of the attack to
its own arsenal this has ranged from
super pressurized jets of its own blood
dangerously radioactive banana beams
firing out of its mouth and even an
incapacitating laughter blast gained
from an encounter with the adorable
scp-999
it is an absolute swiss army knife of
dangerous anomalous powers and abilities
and if you need any further proof of
that check out our multiple videos on
all the ludicrous failed attempts to
kill this nightmare lizard and in this
corner we've got
scp-096 the shy guy while 682 is
freakishly adaptable in most situations
scp-096 is pretty much unstoppable this
long gangly creep will murder anyone who
sees even the tiniest glimpse of its
face with such ferocity that not even a
trace of the body will remain it does
this by entering what many call its rage
state activated by the sudden immense
distress of its face being seen when it
enters this state the scp foundation has
only one prerogative get themselves and
anyone else out of its way because you
will not stop this thing until it's
killed its target all the scp foundation
has ever been able to do is wait until
after the target has been obliterated
and then come in to bag its head when it
enters its docile state almost nothing
else has even successfully slowed it
down while they have been capable of
damaging its flesh the monster skeleton
seems to be utterly indestructible and
its damaged flesh has proven
consistently able to grow back the
monster seems to be immune to everything
from pain to cold and moves at such a
speed that it's pretty much impossible
to escape for long so when you factor in
an indestructible body immense strength
immense speed and an unstoppable urge to
kill anyone who sees its face you're
looking at a formidable opponent it's
only natural that the foundation would
want to use 096 in their 682 cross tests
so what exactly happened when the mobile
task force entered the room after this
first epic battle what did they find
inside the chamber in the grisly
aftermath scp-019 lay crumpled in the
corner wheezing scared covered in its
own blood 682 was barely recognizable
096 had reduced it to a quarter of its
original size the rest having been
utterly torn to shreds both had narrowly
survived the encounter but it was an
epic battle neither of them would ever
forget though this was especially true
for scp-096
you see as we alluded to earlier
scp-682 is used to taking a kicking at
this point it hasn't ever truly been
killed but it's been beaten eaten burned
zapped and smashed within an inch of its
life more times than you can count 096
on the other hand was not used to not
being able to utterly eliminate its prey
while it is impossible to speculate
what's going on inside
scp-096's mind all evidence points
towards getting a draw in this battle
seriously damaging
scp-096's confidence now every time
foundation personnel tries to bring 096
into 682's containment chamber he begins
crying and scratching at his own face
why is he scared of 682 is he humiliated
thinking of the fight he wasn't able to
win or is the very idea of someone
seeing his face and him not being able
to immediately kill them just too
unbearably stressful seeing as the shy
guy's mouth is only good for two things
and neither of them are for talking
we'll never truly know but either way
it's clear that 096 has no interest in a
rematch but what if that changed what if
096 realized that it was wasting its
potential it managed to get scp-682
three-quarters of the way to death last
time what could stop it from getting
that last quarter sure nothing has ever
killed scp-682 before but there's a
first time for everything right maybe
096 would have a rocky style training
montage where he rebuilds his confidence
and becomes the underdog he was always
meant to be he'd walk right up to that
big nasty reptile and give him the
rematch of the century what would happen
then now we give the floor to you the
loyal viewers of scp explained here are
some of your thoughts theories and
opinions on a potential historic rematch
between these two creeps
let's get ready to rumble
i really wanted an excuse to say that
ooh i really like saying that pingu with
an axe said if 682's adaptability is
based around his ability to develop
countermeasures to any damage inflicted
or in the case of 173 a countermeasure
to the cause of said damage i imagine
682 would turn his skin entirely
reflective causing 096 to see his own
face and the feedback loop would break
his mind
interesting whether this would work is
all dependent on whether
scp-096 can actually see or if it is
merely capable of psychically intuiting
when someone else sees its face if the
latter is true then this particular
adaptation wouldn't do much good for
scp-682
random users said if this is after their
first cross test and they were forced to
interact again they wouldn't attempt to
fight each other i feel like they'd form
a truce and take out the researchers on
site yeah this would be one of the worst
case scenarios whether even the scp
foundation could handle a simultaneous
682 and 096 breach without bringing in
hammer down is an open question rahman
vanken said simple after the first
encounter when 096 stopped attacking 682
682 will grow eyes that filter out 096's
face the next time organic scramble
goggles dr dan would be fuming with
jealousy coupe sader said i really want
scp-096 to win so i'm sending him a
blind personal trainer so he can beat
the snot out of scp-682
this is exactly the kind of help
scp-096 needs he's got the rage
endurance and strength with a little
help getting his form and technique in
order he'd be an even more formidable
opponent kyoto rio said i'd like to
imagine 096 after playing with 682 for
so long would try to eat 682 in a vain
attempt to kill it only to gain 682's
abilities and vice versa either of these
options would be horrifying
scp-096 with 682's abilities or 682 with
096's abilities would likely be a truly
perfect killing machine that's
terrifying autumn said what if they just
shared a nice cold drink while playing
mario kart i'm sure 096 would be the
white shy guy character in every race
personally we love this idea and we
think 682 would go for bowser i
personally go for luigi ibrahim timur
said 682 would win eventually it's way
more intelligent adaptive and overall
malicious while 096 acts just on
instinct this is undeniably a good point
what 682 lacks in sheer savagery it
makes up for in its ruthless calculating
intelligence could this give it the edge
over 096 monomoy mukherjee said that
fight would be interesting because both
of them now know how they attack and
what their attacks are nice segway due
to the relatively mindless nature of 096
as far as we're aware it's probably
unable to learn from experience
682 however would have the advantage of
knowing how 096 operates in the second
battle devon smith said as much as i'd
like to see how this would play out i
imagine 096 can't manage more than other
scps have in the past not to downplay
him but he might need some extra friends
to do a whole lot more damage it's
undeniable that going in with tag team
partners would better 096's chances of
taking the lizard down however due to
scp-096's shyness and tendency to kill
everyone and everything that looks at
him he doesn't have many friends looking
to volunteer 9 tails said 096 will cry
in the corner while 682 starts attacking
it eventually it gets confused that 096
isn't fighting back after an hour and
begins to adapt to it and becomes docile
forever okay look while it's unlikely
that this would happen it's certainly
nice to imagine isn't it adam britton
said narratively it needs to conclude
with a reason to never try it again so
i'm going to say that 682 will
telepathically project the image of 096
into the site staff or the entire human
psychospace
yikes
this is a possibility so terrifying and
honestly plausible that it's making us
regret wanting to see this rematch all
together chaos insurgency said i think
682 would just think for damn sake just
leave me alone given he's been through
more termination attempts than scp 5031
can count on its fingers who could blame
him for getting a little frustrated
michael porter said i think that 682 and
096 would take each other to court for
aggravated assault against the other
either one of them will get sentenced to
death and will unsurprisingly not die or
the two team up to kill the entire
courtroom and they walk out as a new
serial killing team the real question is
what kind of lawyers would represent a
pair of murderous anomalous monsters in
court better call saul ari workman said
maybe if we try being nice to them for
once we can offer them a cup of tea and
get them both a therapist 682 will talk
all his hate away and then realize his
wrongdoing and become an activist and
096 would become very confident about
his face and become a model there
problem solved hey when people strive
towards self-improvement we're all
winners but we don't know if we can stay
the same for 682-096
even if this rematch ever did happen
perhaps it'd be just another draw an
unstoppable force against an immovable
object but other matchups may be more
clear-cut what kind of versus battles
would you like to see us cover in the
future what scps would you really love
to see duke it out let us know in the
comments and keep an eye out on the
community posts in order to throw in
your anomalous two cents for our next
versus battle now go check out scp-682
waze scp foundation tried to kill hard
to destroy reptile and
scp-096 shy guy escape incident 096-1-a
containment breach for more of the scoop
on these two star anomalous combatants